david yeah brian a long day for us and a
long day for everybody working inside
it's been a long
four months as well and just in the past
couple of minutes the senate
passing that mining tax bringing in
millions of dollars for education
i want to bring in now eight news now
analyst steve sibelius and
you're also a government and politics
center with the editor with the
review journal it's quite the title we
love titles here but let's talk about
this mining tax not necessarily
the most interesting topic but something
that's been going back and forth here
the past couple of weeks
yeah absolutely it in fact it passed
both houses so it will be on its way to
the governor
a number of republicans two in the
assembly and even more
four in the state senate voted for this
tax that's unusual but it's a result of
a lot of behind the scenes work terms of
collecting a compromise
and convincing people that the amount of
money that this is going to send
directly to education was something that
was worthwhile
now you heard that a lot in the speeches
on the floor right in 170 million
dollars
over two years 15 million dollars from
federal money not the mining money but
federal money
going to charter schools are you
surprised that they were able to do this
in the last couple of hours here not
really
i think the surprise was getting the
republican votes they needed to get
two-thirds they got two-thirds
exactly in the assembly a little more
than that actually in the state
senate but i think the amount of money
that's going in was really what put it
over the top there are a few other
things in there
opportunity scholarships which is very
important republicans is in there a few
other incentives if you will
to get that bill passed so i i wasn't
surprised about the timing too because
in this building
a lot of things happen on the last day
right so we're at 6 30 here we got about
what
i'm bad at math five hours left we got
that a public option which would create
a public health option a public
insurance option
we're still waiting for final votes on
that one of the many topics we're
talking about the likelihood now when we
get to you know
deadline day here deadline hour can
anything happen
yes absolutely anything can happen i've
seen bills
go all session sitting in one committee
and be passed out
in a matter of minutes in the closing
days of a session
i've also seen bills that look like they
were going to pass die in the end
so really anything can happen the public
option bill is one that
democratic senate majority leader nicole
cannazzaro introduced the
democrats really want it it received
democratic majority support
so i think the odds are good that that
one will also have a final passage and
go over to the courtyard to the governor
all right steve sebelius thanks so much
and we'll see what happens of course
we'll keep posted
coming up on eight news now at 11 also
on facebook twitter and 80snow.com
we're live in carson city i'm david
charns 8 news now